>> WITH ME IS CONGRESSWOMAN
NANCY MACE.
NICE TO SEE YOU TODAY.
>> GOOD MORNING.
>> I GUESS WHAT I WANT TO KNOW
IS HOW DOES THIS HELP SOLVE THE
PROBLEM ON THE BORDER AND WHERE
CAN YOU FIND SOLUTIONS MAYBE
WITH DEMOCRATS?
>> LAST YEAR PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
ADMINISTRATION WAS DOING SIMILAR
THINGS, RELOCATING THE
IMMIGRANTS.
IT'S HYPOCRITICAL ONE SIDE
BASHING THE OTHER BECAUSE BOTH
SIDES HAVE DONE IT AND ARE DOING
IT.
I DON'T THINK THE ISSUE IS THAT
COMPLICATED.
WHEN YOU LOOK AT THE VISA ISSUES
WE HAVE, IF WE COULD LOOK AT
RAISING THOSE ARBITRARY CAPS.
PEOPLE DON'T NOTABLY WANT
CITIZENSHIP.
THEY WANT TO WORK AND GO HOME
AND SEND WHAT THEY MAKE BACK
HOME TO THEIR COUNTRIES.
THE OTHER WAYS IS LOOKING AT
SUPPLY CHAINS AND IN SOUTH
AMERICA WHERE COUNTRIES PROSPER,
THERE'S PEACE, LESS ILLEGAL
IMMIGRATION AND THERE'S GOOD
JOBS AND SAFE NEIGHBORHOODS.
>> OF COURSE THE PROBLEM HERE IS
THE COUNTRY MOST OF THEM ARE
COMING FROM, VENEZUELA,
NICARAGUA AND CUBA, WE DON'T
HAVE THE ABILITY TO NEGOTIATE.
THE SENIOR SENATOR IN YOUR
STATE, LINDSEY GRAHAM, HAS
PROPOSED A NATIONAL BAN ON
ABORTION AFTER 15 WEEKS.
YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT THE
EXCEPTION THAT HE HAS.
>> STARTING OUT BOTH SIDES RIGHT
NOW, NEITHER ONE REALLY SEEMED
WILLING TO NEGOTIATE.
BUT STARTING AT GESTATIONAL
LIMITS, WHETHER THAT'S 15, 20
WEEKS IS A GOOD PLACE TO START,
THERE'S NO CONSENSUS ON ABORTION
FOR ANY REASON, THERE'S NO
CONSENSUS ON BANNING ALL
ABORTIONS.
FINDING THAT MIDDLE GROUND, THAT
COMMON GROUND, JESS STATION IS A
GREAT PLACE TO START BUT WE
SHOULD HAVE EXCEPTION FOR RAPE.
I WAS READING THAT A WOMAN HAD
TO TRAVEL ALL THE WAY FROM
LOUISIANA TO NEW YORK BECAUSE
SHE WAS CARRYING A FETUS WITH NO
SCHOOL.
THOSE KIND OF THINGS CAN IMPACT
A WOMAN'S HEALTH BUT MAYBE SURE
WE ARE TRYING TO PROTECT THEM.
AT SOME POINT WHERE DO YOU MAKE
THE DETERMINATION THAT THE RIGHT
TO LIFE SHOULD BE PROTECTED?
>> THERE ARE EXCEPTION FOR RAPE
AND INCEST.
>> FOR ME, I WAS RAPED WHEN I
WAS 16.
IT'S HARROWING.
IT'S BEEN A LIFETIME OF TRAUMA
FOR MOST WOMEN MYSELF.
I TALKED ABOUT MY STORY THREE
YEARS AGO IN 2019 WHEN SOUTH
CAROLINA WAS DOING ITS HEARTBEAT
BILL AND THAT WAS 20 YEARS AFTER
MY TRAUMA AND THE WAY WOMEN ARE
TREATED WHEN THEY COME FORWARD
IS DISGUSTING.
I CAN'T IMAGINE A YOUNG WOMAN
HAVING TO REPORT THAT --
>> SO YOU COULD NOT GO FOR THE
LINDSEY GRAHAM BILL?
>> NOT AS IT STANDS.
THE OTHER IS PUTTING DOCTORS
AWAY IN PRISON.
WE GOT TO HAVE LEGISLATION THAT
CAN BE BIPARTISAN.
THOSE ARE SOME OF THE DETAILS
THAT HAVE TO BE WORKED OUT.
>> YOU ARE, I UNDERSTOOD AND I
READ THIS, AND I WAS A LITTLE
SURPRISED, THE CHAIR OF THE GOLF
CAUCUS.
>> CO-CHAIR.
>> HOW DO YOU GET A JOB LIKE
THAT?
YOU HOSTED GREG NORMAN WITH THE
LIV GOLF TOUR.
THAT WAS PRETTY CONTROVERSIAL.
WHAT DID YOU WANT TO KNOW FROM
GREG NORMAN?
>> LIV GOLF, THEY WERE UP ON THE
HILL FOR THE FIRST TIME.
IT WAS MORE OR LESS AN
EDUCATIONAL SESSION,
INFORMATIONAL SESSION ABOUT WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO.
SOUND LIKE THEY'VE GOT A COUPLE
TOURNAMENTS HERE IN THE U.S.
THIS YEAR AND THEY WANT TO GO
AND THE WORLD AND UNDERSTANDING
WHY THEY'RE THERE AND WHAT
THEY'RE TRYING TO DO AND JUST
LISTEN AT THIS POINT.
>> OBVIOUSLY THE SUPPORT OF THE
SAUDIS DON'T THIS IS JUST
RESULTING IN BILLIONS IN P.R.
FOR THE KINGDOM OF SAUDI ARABIA.
>> THEY'RE INVESTED 40 BILLION
PLUS IN AMERICAN COMPANIES.
THEY'RE INVESTED IN STOCK IN
STARBUCKS AND APPLE, FOR
EXAMPLE.
THEY HAVE COURSES HERE.
WHERE DO WE DRAW A LINE IF WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE THIS DEBATE.
IT'S A GOOD DEBATE TO HAVE BUT
THEY'RE ALREADY INVESTED IN
AMERICAN COMPANIES.
DO YOU CIRCLE IT AROUND GOLF OR
LOOK AT THE ENTIRE SPECTRUM.
IS THE MONEY ALL SAUDI ARE IS
THERE INVESTMENT FROM OTHERS?
THE TEAM PLAYING THAT LIV WANTS
TO DO, THEY ARE WANT TO GIVE
PLAYERS OWNERSHIP.
AND THEN THERE'S THE ANTI-TRUST
ISSUE THAT PHIL MICKELSON HAS
RAISED THOSE ISSUES.
I WANT TO HEAR FROM THE PLAYERS
NEXT.
THAT WOULD BE GOOD TO HEAR WHERE
THEY'RE COMING FROM
GREAT TO SEE YOU. THANKS FOR COMING IN.